Speaker 1: When the people who follow
you politically. Our number one,
willing and able to be convinced of anything you
tell them, even if it's not true. And number two,
willing to do violence, you have to be really
careful when you're telling them lies. And this is
more true than ever with the modern reactionary,
right? We might call it the neo reactionary,
right. I don't know what to call them, because
again, as I've said before, these Trumpists aren't
conservative by the traditional definitions.
They weren't even really involved in politics,
many of them until Trump came up. There really
are neo reactionary movement. And the problem
is that the people feeding them drivel and pablum
have no consideration for whether these folks are
going to hear what they say and go and take real
world violent action. And it's already happened.
It's already happened. But we're going to talk
about in a moment. But this brings us to something
that radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene recently said she and some others
have gotten on this idea that anybody who supports
Judge Katju Brown Jackson for the Supreme Court
is either a pedophile or is pro pedophilia. Now
you might say, Wait, but David, what? That doesn't
make any sense. You'd be right. It doesn't make
any sense. But but the way they have spun this is.
Judge Jackson has issued sentences for all sorts
of different crimes to all sorts of different
people over many years as a judge in different on
different courts. And sometimes the sentence she
gives is not what the state asks for, what the
prosecution asks for. Sometimes it's somewhere
between what the prosecution asks for and what the
defense asks for. And as all judges do, she weighs
factors and issues a sentence. And the fact that
that happened with some examples of individuals
who had explicit images of children, what is
sometimes called child porn. Although I don't
think that's a good term because porn typically is
legal in between involving consenting individuals,
child porn is something very different. I've
already said that sometimes her sentence has
departed from the recommendation or what the
prosecutors wanted, so they're saying she's
pro pedophile and the people supporting her might
be pedophiles themselves. Here is such an example
of Marjorie Taylor Greene saying that
Speaker 2: the Democrats are the party
of pedophiles. The Democrats are the party of
princess predators from Disney. The Democrats
are the party of teachers, elementary school
teachers trying to trying to transition their
elementary school aged children and convince them
there are different gender. This is the party of
their identity, and their identity is the most
disgusting, evil, horrible things happening in
our country. And that's why we have to say it. We
have to be willing to say it. And no matter how
many little blue check marks get their feelings
hurt on Twitter. So, you know it's worth to.
Speaker 1: This is liable to get people killed.
Now, why is that? Well, we have a dangerous cult
here. We have a dangerous cult that refuses
to or is enabled to think critically about
the things that they're being told. We have a
cult that by a large, much larger share than
independents and Democrats believes it's OK to use
real world violence to achieve political goals.
So they believe things that aren't true and
they're willing to use violence. And this could
genuinely lead some of Marjorie Taylor Greene's
followers and other Trumpists to go and target
Democrats with guns, or even the three Republicans
who said they'd be voting for Judge Katagiri Brown
Jackson. Remember, we looked at this on the show
a couple of days ago, Marjorie Taylor Greene
tweeted. Murkowski, Collins and Romney are
pro pedophile. They just voted for Kay B.J..
This is extraordinarily dangerous, and we have
examples of it. Remember, there was this one story
of the man who was targeting Liberals and the
Tides Foundation. This is an old story. This
is 11 years old. I remember covering this when
it happened. Byron Williams told investigators
he wanted to start a revolution by killing
people of importance at the Tides Foundation
and the ACLU. Where did he get that
idea? Well, he got it, among others
from Glenn Beck. And he said that when California
Highway Patrol pulled him over, we did the story.
We have the Pizzagate shooter,
Pizzagate gunman. This is from 2017
sentenced to four years in prison. This was
a guy who became convinced, thanks to what
Republicans were saying at the time, that Comet
Ping Pong, a pizza shop in D.C., was somehow the
nexus of some kind of child sex trafficking
ring involving Democrats. And I mean, listen,
I don't remember exactly all the claims they were
making, but it was completely and totally bonkers.
There was the pipe bomber, the Trumpist pipe
bomber. I don't even remember the date it was
while Donald Trump was president, who was also
shot. This is not like maybe it'll happen someday.
We know that these types of comments from people
like Marjorie Taylor Greene are stochastic
terrorism. It's extraordinarily dangerous and
she's going to get people killed. Let me know
your thoughts. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and remember that Tuesday, April 19th, we'll be
doing the next David Pakman show Town Hall. It'll
be at 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel. That's youtube.com slash Pacman
live. We'll take a quick break and be right back.